مع من يشعر الانسان بالراحه مع اهله مع
اسرته مع اصدقائه مع من يحب لكن يا راويه
العلاقات الاكثر سمي وافق دراسه جديده
تقول تاتيك من المقربين اللي يساعدونك
احيانا ويودونك في احيان اخرى مثلا الصديق
السام
او المدير الذي يمارس ضغطا غير منطقي عليك
طبعا هذه الدراسه مشاهدينا اشارت اليها
صحيفه اظهرت انه العلاقات المتناقضه يمكن
ان تضر بصحتك فالبالغون يعانون من ارتفاع
ضغط الدم وارتفاع معدلات ضربات القلب بعد
التفاعل عاده مع الاشخاص الذين اثاروا
مشاعر مختلطه اكثر من التفاعل مع اولئك
الناس الذين اثروا مشاعر سلبيه حتى تخيلوا
الدراسات اوضحت ان القاء التحيه على نفس
الشخص الذي لا يجرحك او الذي يجرحك لا
يخفف من المشاعر السيئه اللي في داخلك بل
يضخمها ويترك اثرا في قلبك وفي دمك ايضا
يعني يمشي معاش مع الكريات الدم البيضاء
والحمراء
على كل حال سال الناس مشاهدينا في مصر كيف
تتعامل مع العلاقات المتقلبه والسامه في
حياتك لنستمع ماذا اجابوا
[موسيقى]
ببعد عنه او بتل وبخلي علاقتي بيني وبينه
بتبقى يعني علاقه عاديه جدا صباح الخير
صباح النور لو هو مثلا ايجابي معي في حاجه
معينه استمر معه واسمع ايجابياته لو جه
مثلا بقى سلبي او جه فجاه اختلف معايا او
لقيته عمل حاجه بيخزني فيها ما ابصش
للجانب السلبي ده لان لو بصيت له انا هتعب
اتعامل بطريقتين يا اما بالتجاهل يا اما
بالتجاهل
[موسيقى]
لكن اللي انا بتعامل معاه باسلوبه ممكن ان
انا يقلب معاه الموضوع كمان بموضوع اللي
انا ابدا اللي انا اتقلب عليه بس في الاخر
بتعمل باسلوب في حد ذاته يعني الصحابه
السامه ما بنحاولش ان احنا نقرب منهم ولا
نخرج معاهم لان الواحد بيبقى محتاج دعم
خصوصا ان احنا في ايام صعبه اي حد مثلا
حاول ياذيك او يحاول يعكنن عليك حياتك
تتجنبه تماما وده افضل حاجه يعني كاشخاص
[موسيقى]
الان في الاستوديو مشاهدينا اختصاصي
العلاج النفسي محمد فريح اهلا بك دكتور
اهلا وسهلا اهلا وسهلا فيك صباح النور طيب
خلينا ندخل في الموضوع على طول دراسه
الحقيقه بتخلي الانسان محتار اكثر مما هو
محتار اصلا لانه كل هدول الناس اللي
قريبين منه هو مضطر يتعامل معهم خصوصا اذا
كانوا افراد عائله فاذا كانت هاي العلاقه
هي اللي بتعمل له كل هذا القلق وهذا
التقلب وعدم الراحه في الحياه كيف السبيل
يعني انه يكون مرتاح بحياته خلينا نحكي عن
العلاقات الصحيه عشان حتى نحصر السامه
صحيه شخصين بيمشوا مع بعض بيرتاحوا مع بعض
بيختلفوا مع بعض بيوصلوا لحل بشكل سريع
جدا
فهاي العلاقه الطبيعيه في راحه في عدم
اتفاق ولكنه محلول بثواني العلاقات السامه
لا يوجد حلول بثواني الشخص اللي يتمتع
بسميه عاليه في العلاقات في عنده دائما
يعني طريقه لجعل الموقف معقد
فمثلا
شو حابين نشرب اليوم فلان حكى هو الثاني
بيقول ليش قهوه
فبلش يعطي طب شو نوع القهوه طب شو هي
القهوه طيب من وين رح نروح المكان بعيد
المكان قريب دائما في احساس بانه في في
سترس عليك وانت بتتناقش معه للاسف هذا
محمد هل في علاقات او فيه علاقات تكون
علاقات طبيعيه ومن ثم تتحول شيئا فشيئا من
السميه حتى تصبح علاقات سامه زوجه وزوجته
اخ واخو ايا كان او حتى زملاء العمل
كيف
اتعامل مع هذه العلاقات اللي هي تقتلني
رويدا رويدا هلا لما يكون في خلافات بين
شخصين هون دخلنا بموضوع خلاف زوجي او خلاف
بين امزجه هون موضوعنا نقول انه المشكله
في العلاقه انهم غير هي العلاقه سامه في
العلاقه السامه احنا بنحكي عن شخص يتمتع
بصفات عاديه وفي مقابله صديق او زوجه او
زوجه عنده مشكله في التواصل
السميه بالمفهوم يعني الان الشائع هي
التواصل يعني هو ايش يعني علاقه سامي اكيد
هو احنا كنا بنحكي باسم البدن طب كيف يعني
ليش في فلان بنعتبر او بنحس انه هو بسم
البدن بس فلان ما بسم البدن عادي شيء شيء
بطاقه هذا الانسان كمان
في طاقه سلبيه في احساس دائما عنده هو انه
ما في خيارات كثيره وكانه للعلم لما نتكلم
عن السميه بنتكلم عن اضطرابات شخصيه يعني
من بعيد خلينا نقول محمد
كيف انا استطيع ان اكمل المشوار مع علاقه
اشعر فيها بالسميه العاليه من قبل الطرف
الاخر بس مضطر اني اكمل هلا في بعض
الاقتراحات اولا بده نسعى للتغيير بمعنى
انه يوضح ان هناك مشكله وهذا الكلام بده
مرات تدخل قد يكون طرف خارج سواء كان مرشد
نفسي
في طرف ثالث الان توضيح ان هناك في مشكله
في التواصل وتكون واضحه الامور بمعنى
الحديث عن السميه يعني ما راح نقول له انت
انت سام لكن حنقول انه الانتقاد المتواصل
ترى مؤذي التدقيق على بعض الامور بشكل
سلبي مريح التحدث عن انت انت انت انت
احتياجاتك او ايش اللي بتحبه انت غير
موجود
امام وجهه حتى يشوف
حاله بالطريقه
توصل الامور يعني انت عارف مرات الفراق
طبعا بس يعني انا انتهى وقتنا ولكن حابه
احكي عن نقطه ثانيه باختصار وبسرعه في ناس
عندهم هاي الطاقه السلبيه ولكن برضو عندهم
كثير صفات جيده واحنا مش حابين نخسرهم من
حياتنا ولكن مش مضطرين على هاي العلاقه
ولكن بنحب انها تكون موجوده بحياتنا فكيف
بنقدر نحط حد للجزء السيء اللي باثر علينا
سلبا ونخلي الجزء الجميل من هذه العلاقه
مهارات في التحمل بدك ترفعي سقف التحمل
بهذا الموضوع
بعرف انك تتحمل
شكرا جزيلا محمد شكرا جزيلا اختصاصي على
نفسي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات